pas stéphane rozès politologue et
président de cap conseil analyse et
perspective nous a également rejoint
pour décrypter ces résultats ces
résultats je vous le rappelle marquée
notamment par un très fort un taux
d'abstention stéphane rozès bonjour
bonjour effectivement oui très fort taux
d'abstention pardon excusez moi on a eu
déjà l'occasion de l'évoquer ensemble
cela résulte de deux choses le premier
évidemment le contexte de la crise
sanitaire de la crise pandémie qui avait
déjà marqué une aube une augmentation de
l'abstention de 20 points lors du
premier tour auquel il faut rajouter
alors que nous sommes en plein
déconfinement le fait que ce scrutin a
été scindée en deux une élection
majoritaire à deux tours c'est un rite
républicain où il ya une unité de lieu
de temps et d'enjeux et au premier tour
on vote
quant à sa préférence au second tour on
se rassemblait tout ça dans une même
dynamique
or cette dynamique qui a été interrompue
pendant trois mois
a fortiori par une crise qui fait que
les français citoyens dans leurs
municipalités ont reconsidéré un tout
petit peu les enjeux un peu différemment
donc les landes du premier tour il
devait amener au second tour un
ressaisissement a été coupée d'où cette
abstention absolument historique et vous
l'analysez également par la peur du
virus
on parle je l'analyse on partie bien sûr
par la peur du virus mais surtout par le
fait au fond que alors même que les
maires sont les élus les plus populaires
et qu'avant le coc vide
les instituts de sondage montre et qui
aurait au moins une participation égale
à vous
locaux vides à bousculer les enjeux
locaux et que maintenant les français
sont dans des inquiétudes plutôt de
nature nationale autour du déconfinement
et de la pleine conscience qu'à la
rentrée d'octobre nous allons subir un
choc économique et social très dur ce
qu'il fallait que non pas au travers de
cette abstention
les français se détournent de la
démocratie locale de l'importance de
l'échelon municipal mais disons que
quelque chose s'est rompu dans le choix
même de faire un deuxième tour
déconnecté du premier tour et de le
faire maintenant ça a été décidée parce
que le président raconte tout de suite
maintenant passer à autre chose pour
mettre en oeuvre son nouveau chemin s'il
a annoncé comme valant pour plusieurs
années mettre en place un nouveau
gouvernement au travers de son
remaniement
stéphane rozès un paris mantes et on
peut le dire ce soir pour la république
en marche quelles perspectives pour le
parti présidentiel maintenant selon vous
c'est un pari manqué il fallait s'y
attendre
au fur et à mesure des élections
municipales des enjeux locaux faisaient
plus nous évidemment commentateurs
nationaux on a tendance à voir les
municipales en voyant ça de haut
mais les motivations de vote étaient
bien des motivations très local d'une
part et d'autre part les les têtes de
listes ayant vocation à devenir les
futures mères la personnalité
l'incarnation de ses têtes de listes
jouer plus que le projet et a fortiori
le programme
ce qui fait qu'en se présentant devant
les électeurs maintenant sur le platt
les plateaux télé les uns les autres
comment tu en es tu en avant leurs
étiquettes aux blancs national mais au
plan local c'est pas du tout ce qui
s'est fait ces au clan local où on a mis
en
avant le projet municipal la personne de
la tête de liste son projet sa personne
et on a mis très discrètement les
étiquettes dont tout ça pour dire qu'il
n'était pas aisé pour une formation
arrivant avec essentiellement des cadres
issus de la société civile de pouvoir si
rapidement s'impliquer et c'était
l'erreur d'emmanuel macron et de la
république en marche que de décliner au
plan des municipalités ce qu'avait été
les scores à la présidentielle analyse
hâtive et même aux européennes donc en
amour ces élections ont été nos haïk de
situations locales il n'était bien
présomptueux de la part du président et
la république en marche que de croire
que il a l'air je dirais faire bonne
figure où s'implanter ça n'a pas été le
cas
c'était de toute façon dans un contexte
difficile de très grande défiance au
plan national à l'égard de l'exécutif
après l'échiné jaune après la réforme
des retraites après le début de la
triche du coaching qui montrait
l'impréparation des gouvernants et
l'impéritie de l'état même si au moment
dé confinement et choses sont à mêler
les mieux mais c'était très présomptueux
de la part de la république en marche
d'annoncer des départs qu il allait
décliner au plan municipal et famars
priorité au direct on à rachida dati qui
va s'exprimer de son qg de campagne et
on reparle de ces élections évidemment
avec vous pensez vous est ce que le le
paysage politique est redessiné ce soir
après ces élections municipales on a vu
la multiplicité des délices dans
certaines communes les partis
traditionnels qui finalement ne sont pas
enterrés comme on aurait pu le croire
lors des élections européennes comment
est-ce que vous analysez ce paysage
politique ce soir en fait comme jamais
ces municipales de ce sont quand même
des roulés dans le contexte
très particulier qui a cassé la
dynamique de premier tour mais néanmoins
avec des motivations de vote très très
locale si on prend paris les études
menées durant les municipales montrait
une aspiration à trouver les bons
équilibres pour les parisiens entre une
vie quotidienne et puis dynamique de la
métropole qui semblait peu à peu échappé
au parisien et là puisqu'on parlait des
questions d'écologie
l'écologie est devenue un support ici
comme ailleurs au fond à l'idée qu'il
pourrait y avoir un autre type de
développement plus soucieux de
l'harmonie du quotidien de la vie
quotidienne pour essayer de tenir
ensemble
l'attractivité économique le
développement économique d'une grande
métropole et un quotidien des parisiens
qui devient de plus en plus difficile et
la anne hidalgo art avec un bilan très
médiocres voire mauvais quand on compare
les bilans a estimé avec d'autres villes
et même départ 60 % des parisiens qui ne
souhaitait pas sa réélection mais au
fond comme par exemple durant le cocig
la mère anne hidalgo a trouvé à cette
preuve de dynamisme et a bien occupé sa
fonction de maire durant cette crise et
surtout ça a été dit
parce que ceux qui aspiraient à un autre
type de projet à un autre type
d'équipement municipales n'ont pas
réussi à se mettre d'accord en terme de
projet politiquement au fond anne
hidalgo repasse mais le défi pour elle
va être de réussir maintenant et demain
au fond il n'a pas vraiment réussi
durant son précédent
ah donc ça veut dire pour elle une
réinvention nécessaire alors elle a
annoncé que les équipes étaient
renouvelées mais va savoir aussi
renouveler son projet mais pour répondre
à votre question de nature plus générale
nous commentateurs on a tendance à
nationaliser ces municipales mais dans
la réalité ces municipales ne sont une
mosaïque de situations locales très
différentes et les nez de le contexte
national hormis locaux vides et la
coupure du scrutin ont 2 qui a
complètement rendu atone la dynamique
attendue de la municipale mais pour le
reste les gens ne se sont pas déterminé
de façon substantielle sur des question
d'étiquette nationale
ils ont regardé leur situation locale et
ils ont comparé les projets et lycées
qui à les entendre on l'a vu et noir
philippe qui s'est présenté sans
étiquette ce soir qu'est ce que ça
révèle ça révèle un tout petit peu ce
qu'on s'est dit c'est à dire que les
personnalités locales n'ont pas
concrètement nuit comme autrefois en
avant des étiquettes nationale
d'autre part il y avait une forme de
prudence pour le premier mini c'était
une façon de dire que son ancrage au
havre devait prévaloir sur sa gestion
gouvernementale dans un moment où un an
après l'élection d' emmanuel macron les
choses ont commencé à se déliter
fortement entre l'exécutif et le pays
donc c'était une façon pour edouard
philippe de mener une campagne avec une
latitude total sur des thèmes du havre
rue finale et dans le prolongement le
premier ministre edouard philippe pons
aux fonds gérés
gouverner les hommes à wavre en prenant
compte une culture locale très
particulière très marquée par une
histoire ouvrière et on l'a bien vu dans
l'hommage rendu par le maire
nouvellement élu à son adversaire au
sénateur communiste 1 il ya forcément
comme dans une villa microclimat donc en
connaît bien les situations locales
quand on connaît bien la vie politique
locale
on sait à quel point chaque candidat
fusse-t-il premier ministre doit partir
de façon immanente des situations
locales
alors chiche oui pardon qu'est-ce que sa
victoire révèle selon vont c'est qu'il
ya des dissensions avec le président de
la république pendant cette crise il ya
eu quelques quelques tensions entre
matignon et l'elysée on sait qu'il est
sur la sellette peut-être avec un
remaniement annoncé pour peut-être la
semaine prochaine sa victoire ça va être
compliqué pour un emmanuel macron de le
mettre de côté voire philippe selon vous
ça va être un peu plus compliqué pendant
le dépôt finement le premier ministre
-plus parti que le président de la de du
de l'assortiment des français pourquoi
parce que le président était sur un
registre très idéelle trait sur le
souhaitent un dés le premier ministre
semblait lui être au plus proche des
préoccupations quotidiennes des français
et donc les français au travers des
sondages ont envoyé une adresse au
président pour que ça soit lui qui soit
comptable de la cohérence entre ce qui
était dit et ce qui était fait et là au
fond edouard fini par occulter un peu la
fonction qu avait en son temps françois
fillon au moment nicolas sarkozy c'est à
dire que au travers des sondages les les
français créditent un premier ministre
qui a une posture qui sont plus adaptées
pour envoyer en fait des messages aux
au président sales c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est que les
sondages réalisés ce soir par certains
instituts montre que les français
souhaiteraient le maintien des doigts
fini et en même temps vous très très
massives loin un remaniement alors là il
ya là il ya une vraie difficulté parce
que le président a annoncé un nouveau
chemin sur plusieurs années d'ailleurs
enjambant la présidentielle il semble
mettre en avant la souveraineté
nationale l'indépendance
bref un retour à des orientations plus
néo bonapartiste là où réellement à la
tête de l'état edouard philippe
représentait plus une droite orléaniste
celle des comptes
le logiciel du pays ce que l'on connaît
bien et on crée une difficulté pour le
président c'est karine peut pas dire
j'ouvre un nouveau chemin avec un
premier ministre qui même si sur le
style est plus apprécié par les français
sur le fond s'était lui qui durant les
gilet jaune ou la réforme des retraites
était le plus dans l'orthodoxie
traditionnel de la droite
les le plus en dissonance avec l'idée
que c'est la france qui décide
la souveraineté de la nation nonobstant
les contraintes de bruxelles
les contraintes européennes donc là le
président va devoir arbitrer et s'il
arbitre du point de vue de la ligne de
pente de la nation vers la souveraineté
alors logiquement il devrait trouver un
autre premier ministre edward finit donc
effectivement il ya un 10 sujets on va
voir si au fond le président se
détermine en fonction de ce qu'il
comprend être les fondamentaux du pays
quant à la tente à l'égard d'un nouveau
gouvernement ou si au fond il regarde et
l'immédiateté
du paysage politique des sondages sa
dette très intéressant de boiro vous à
partir de quels critères ils se
déterminent pour nous présenter son beau
chemin
finalement cette abstention à qui elle
profite en fait elles profitent
réellement à personne mais ça a été dit
ça a été une abstention différentiel
pour des raisons évidentes on peut on
attend dont les analyses plus précises
par bureau de vote mais faisons
l'hypothèse que les personnes âgées sont
allés moins voté par crainte de la
pandémie et dans conte la participation
est faible ce sont évidemment plus tôt
les réseaux militants qui ont le plus
l'importance et puis aussi des réflexes
légitimistes
c'est à dire que le paysage mental des
français avec cette crise pandémique et
d'inquiétude pour le choc économique et
social qui vient c'est un des
représentations très déstabilisé les
français sont inquiets et donc là par
exemple vous citiez nantes forte
abstention et en même temps à nantes
le bilan municipal de la maire sortant
johanna rolland était vraiment très très
bon et donc tout le monde se disait sans
doute que sans problème
elle serait élu d'autant que la liste
europe écologie les verts par la
dynamique de la mère l'a soutenu donc il
ya eu un mix de réflexe légitimiste
favorisant les maires sortants a
fortiori quand c'était de bon maire ou
qu'on avait su durant la crise
duco vide 19 en plus être actif et
positif c'est le cas de johanna rolland
de valérie appellerait ça a été le cas
d'ailleurs à paris où six
pour anne hidalgo donc en un mot cette
abstention a joué plutôt pour les maires
sortants qui avait de bons bilans des
bilans comptables
johanna rolland a été élu avec 60 % des
voix mais ça cette abstention a plutôt
joué pour les électeurs les plus
légitimistes et en même temps pas trop
âgés et ça a pénalisé des formations qui
fonctionne plus en yo yo
selon les taux de participation comme
par exemple le rassemblement le
rassemblement national mais par exemple
sur paraît clairement au premier tour
c'est rachida dati qui a été pénalisé
par la crise du coc vie parce que c'est
pour elle que les écarts étaient les
plus importants entre les dernières
intentions de vote et le vote au moment
du coe j